you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hey folks welcome back to dark horse
podcast
live stream a and q section
extravaganza number 49. we're starting
with the answers this time
we are starting with the answers do it
jeopardy fired by jeopardy
all right all right okay uh obviously we
should start with 42
yes and your turn
well played you got nothing i got
zero it was a bluff yeah i guess okay
we will start with a few questions from
episode 48
and then a question from the discord and
then move into your questions from the
last hour before moving into questions
from
this hour first question from a week ago
can you think of a reason for the
seemingly universal nature of
pilgrimages
across time and cultures
sure yep um yeah i mean i can think of a
lot of them
uh there's one in particular i've spent
a good deal of time thinking about you
and i both have
the uh pilgrimage of the wee troll
people in search of
peyote they cross mexico to collect
peyote
uh once a year and in that case i would
argue
that a the population
has likely moved over this distance
and so a pilgrimage that causes you to
return to some ancestral landscape
regularly a keeps you in contact with
the information about what the
intervening space
looks like that is to say it provides a
regularly updated
map that is not just held by a select
few
right and um so that has
um a great deal of potential importance
just ecologically speaking maintaining
that kind of information in the case of
the we chole and the peyote obviously
the peyote is playing a
tremendous cultural role and so there's
a necessity to move
to another part of the world in order to
do one's daily ecological stuff um
but to maintain contact with the peyote
cactus
would make sense but anyway i guess the
point would be there are a couple of
reasons a couple of styles of reasons
one
it could be that a journey that causes
you to return over some landscape
informs you about something that is
ecologically important to know
it could be that pilgrimages cause you
to basically
touch base with something cultural from
which too much divergence is
a danger and so that there's a
synchronizing aspect that to the extent
that you keep returning to some
location or return to some location at
one point and know that you will at some
point in your life
keeps you from dispensing with all of
the architecture that goes along with
whatever
that cultural tradition has so i would
say it is a kind of
spatial conservatism that has probably
preserved
populations against too much change
great yep i think that's
uh that's spot on and you know to which
i would just add the
what i already said the universal value
of having an accurate and
regularly updating map of the area
around you
perhaps just the area that historically
your people have lived
in or perhaps it's a area of a watershed
you know some some area presumably that
will change over time is all due
some more rapidly than others that would
allow you
to understand what an escape plan might
look like what a new kind of move might
look like
and that is not um that is not static
yeah in terms of a map that was drawn 50
years ago and who knows what's happened
yeah and i guess i would add one more
thing um this came up
in my uh conversation
with christine brophy and scott barry
kaufman on
unity campfire this week but there is
this sense amongst moderns that
you are effectively entitled not to
suffer
not to struggle and that therefore
suffering and struggle
is taken to be some kind of a an
indication of a failure of something
and this is utter nonsense right
struggle
and suffering are inherent to
accomplishment and so
uh i i have a few rituals that i think
of
as toughening myself up you know things
that i know i find unpleasant
and i do them and my sense is this is
necessary for
me to be able to face things that i
don't necessarily see coming
so you can imagine that a population um
choosing a regular struggle um would
keep people
uh in that frame of mind and actually um
uh also fasting could certainly work
this way that
you know that a regular like an annual
fast uh would cause you to keep in touch
with what it's like to be hungry and to
know that it's not the end of the world
absolutely and and no um no coincidence
i think
that some form of pilgrimage and some
form of fast exist in many religions
yes exactly adults born pre-term
have a pre-term behavioral phenotype
resulting in tippiness and neuroticism
how does being born pre-term impact
other animals
so the first answer to that is i don't
know what i'm not sure that
that we know because i'm not sure that
preterm is
reliably enough a thing anywhere else
that it's been
it's been looked at yeah i would say in
nature
in general pre-term is going to mean not
viable
right and so you just you never get to
discovering what the behavioral
phenotype might look like
right on the other hand um runts
are a feature of litters and it's not
pre-term but it has some of those
characteristics and i would say the runt
is going to have uh neuroticism or
something like neuroticism
and insecurity because basically
it is an evolutionary attempt
in it you know you can imagine if a
pregnancy starts
and then the year turns out spectacular
than having produced an extra that is
that is denied resources in utero but
can be
brought to full size is an evolutionary
win
and so that individual should expect
that to the extent that it's not a good
year that they're actually
most likely to perish and maybe to be
abandoned by
by the parent and so um you would
imagine that neuroticism and
demonstrating strength and
all of these things that might increase
the chances of surviving to adulthood
would be features of that personality
type yeah i'm not sure
demonstrating strength it seems to me
would be a feature and yet it's not
i don't know i've never heard this
pre-term behavioral phenotype term
before
um but timidness and eroticism um
strike me as not in in line with
demonstrating strength but we do see
that
in rents of litters and of course you
know humans humans don't bear litters
humans ten
the vast majority of human births are
singletons uh with twins being a very
small percentage and really more than
that um being almost entirely
a manifestation of modern technology
right
yeah okay
please discuss voting as a right and
responsibility vote your conscience
what effect does not voting have uh
vote shaming topic is this next sentence
i'm not sure exactly what that means
love you guys but
i i like the the general topic here um
is it is it both a right and
responsibility
well i want to be a little careful
because uh i think there is a way
in which it is irresponsibility and i
wish people took it as one but i don't
necessarily think
a uninformed vote is such a great thing
so to the extent that voting is your
responsibility you should figure out
what you should actually be voting for
on the other hand so that
if i may uh it's not that
voting is there is the entirety of the
responsibility if you're going to vote
you should
it should be informed about informed
voting should be the responsibility that
you understand yourself to have not
merely voting
yes but i want to put a giant asterisk
on that because
i thought that was the asterisk i want
to put an asterisk
on the asterisk yeah that does sound
like you yeah it does but
um the thing that we all face in our
voter pamphlets is
almost impenetrable and you can't be
informed and who are these judges and
you know um so the point is to the
extent that there is this temptation
to finger wag at people and say oh
you know those uninformed voters the
point is well we set them up for failure
we set ourselves up for failure
and so ideally what you want is a system
that gives you the ability to vote on
that which you have the ability to be
informed
about and delegates where it needs to
delegate to people who can handle the
responsibility and of course
what we have is a giant you know corrupt
entity
that stands in place of all this and it
loves to hand us
confusing garbage and manipulate us into
feeling emotional about it and all the
things that it does
but ideally yes you would want people to
take
you know voting as a privilege and a
responsibility
and um to treat it very
seriously now one thing i would say is
there's a longer discussion for another
time about the fact
that if you take all of the people who
don't vote
and you separate them into two groups
there are people who
don't care they're apathetic they're not
paying attention
they don't see themselves as having a
stake yeah and then you take
you separate them from the people who
are frustrated and angry that they never
have something
they feel good about voting for yep
right
that second group is very large
and if you compile them with all of the
people who do vote for one of the major
party candidates
there are enough votes in that group
to transform civilization and the fact
that we are told
well first of all we're fine with you
not voting basically
we're going to give you an awful
situation and drive you out and people
are going to feel good about not voting
because they know that voting is stupid
which in some sense it has become
that this causes a collective
failure of imagination that is the
difference between us
succeeding or continuing to fail in the
same way so at some level
we have to rescue the idea of
protest vote from the concept that it is
a pointless waste of your power because
in fact
there's a ton of power in voting for
things
other than the major party candidates if
it registers somewhere
the system you know doesn't like to
count those votes because it doesn't
want there to be power in it it fears
that those who are
angry and disaffected will actually rise
up against the system and insist on
something better
and so what it does is it falsely
convinces us
that we have no power the only thing we
can do is choose between
evils and if we choose to do anything
else that's because we're naive children
who have decided to waste our vote it's
nonsense it's not a waste of a vote
it's a very powerful thing now
personally
i think of myself at the point you know
what do i know i've already lost this
election
i know that my candidate won't win
because my candidate is not running
it's not on the ballot right so i've
already lost this one
does that mean there's nothing to be
done no i'm voting
in the next election right i'm voting in
2020
in the next election by registering the
fact
that i don't accept this lesser evil
garbage
i don't know what that means i'm voting
in 2020 in the next election i don't
know what that sentence means
it means that by voting against the
duopoly
one registers that there is a massive
political movement
waiting to be spoken to and
that that signal is power it is not
power to change things in 2020 but it is
power to change things in the future so
if you think about elections
you know we are basically convinced to
think of elections in isolation
right but it is obviously an iterated
game and if this you know if you were to
analyze them if you were an alien coming
to earth to analyze our elections
you wouldn't sit down and think of them
as one-off puzzles you would think of
them as iterated
yep and that affects the game theory so
think of elections as iterated
and it changes what you ought to do no
and that's actually part of the uh
lesser of two evils argument is it
assumes that you're always an end game
yeah it assumes that you're always an
endgame if you don't do it now
everything will end yep absolutely
actually the next question the final
question from episode 48 is related to
that last one
why does being demanded to vote by
celebrities and the media feel like
propaganda
i've always had a strange feeling about
i voted stickers
and comments like if you don't vote you
can't complain
so i feel like we kind of we kind of you
kind of touched on this but
pick up a little bit more well i would i
would add one thing
i do think you should vote so that it is
not ambiguous as to whether you are
apathetic or disaffected
if you are disaffected you want to
register as disaffected
and not as a non-participant right
and the way to do that is to vote so
it's clear you're willing to spend the
effort and frankly it's not a huge
effort
right but you want to register as
willing to spend the effort
and not up for this [ __ ] right
that's the powerful
move and so you know i do think if you
didn't do that it
makes it ambiguous as to whether or not
you have a right to complain uh to
complain because you might be apathetic
and if you're apathetic or lazy then the
point is actually it does reduce your
right to complain so
i sort of believe it now celebrities
you know unfortunately this is just a
evolutionary it's propaganda
it is propaganda and it's a it's a
novelty problem the fact that
because we are exposed to celebrities
and we recognize them it sort of feels
like they're people in our little town
yeah and they're not yeah right um so
my good friend the person i'll never
meet tells me i need to vote okay
right exactly yeah exactly
okay next question from the discord
server this week
so people on the discord server vote
pose questions uh i as i understand it
and then
vote on which one they want us to
address each week
what would be the best steps towards
returning the k-12 program to a
functional level of employment readiness
in graduates
is there a way we can reduce the
perceived necessity of higher education
and if completeness be restored to a
high school diploma teaching towards
higher education seems off the mark
uh teach i i agree teaching towards
higher ed seems off the mark and you
know this
there are there's the school that we met
at in high school
um and as a as like many other
elite private schools are called college
prep college preparatory
right and that's that is clearly what it
is that they are doing and yet actually
the school where we met did far far far
more than that
and i would say that it did not it also
did not make the mistake of what i think
is
intrinsic to this question which is
employment readiness this is this is the
thing
that we hear from most people who are
saying look the liberal arts have gone
off the rails
that's not what we need we need to know
uh what it is we need to train people to
be ready
um to enter the workforce and be
employable
and that was more true
20 50 and 100 years ago than it is now
and even when it was more true because
the future then was more predictable and
looked more like the immediate past
it was still not the highest and best
goal of education
the highest and best goal of education
should be
helping people realize their full
potential so they can live
as maximally productive however you
define that
and creative and content
i guess citizens of the society in which
they were born
and so that that that liberal arts
goal which is explicitly not about
training
uh it's about thinking um can live side
by side
can exist side by side with the more
sort of trades-oriented goals of of
training
the the additional problem with the
training goal right now is
we don't know what the future looks like
we don't know what employment looks like
we don't know what jobs look like
are going to look like and so the idea
that
especially current educators are going
to be able to train kids
for tomorrow's jobs is laughable
i would say yeah it's laughable on the
other hand i don't think
today's educators are well positioned to
do either job
no they're not um and that's that's a
tragedy so
i i do think that there's something that
haunts this discussion
which is that the choice
we've got a dichotomy which is false
because there's another thing
that we could teach for so in other
words
there's this well you know maybe overly
um simplistic or idealistic
idea of you know empowering you to
see the full glory of the human
experience right the
liberal arts thing which you know if
you're in a position to take advantage
of it
is a great thing if it's done well which
it generally isn't
um and it won't be everyone's cup of tea
or um nor will everyone be in a position
to feel like
they can afford to spend time there well
i i think
if it was done well it would be
everybody's cup of tea because what it
would really be doing is giving you the
higher order tools in order to
figure out what the special puzzles
we're going to play games we're going to
engage in
in in sport with an academic bench yeah
right
if what it did was make you um
really smart and aware
and motivated self-motivated such that
you could do what you set your mind to
right then the point is yeah that's
everybody's cup of tea if you can do it
and
in general we don't think we can do it
because by the time
students get to a place where it might
be done uh
they're too damaged in general for it to
be done and the teachers just
aren't in a position to deliver it less
and less so in some sense yeah
less and less so in part because
teaching now like policing has become
less and less of a vaunted
profession and so people going into it
are less likely to be
sort of the best at what they do that
said there are
many many many awesome teachers out
there who are just hamstrung
yes by and you know this is the bigger
problem i think then that a lot you know
that there are no teachers who can do
the job like no there are plenty of
teachers who can do the job but they're
being prevented from doing
the job precisely because well in part
um the teaching towards the test the
number of days the number of hours in
any given school year that devoted to
prep test prep or test taking and what's
the test for the test is about college
prep
so um you know that's that doesn't serve
actually i think
anyone like if if those teachers were
allowed
to actually teach and uh if the good
teachers were allowed some freedom
to actually do what they could do then
then we might have a better educational
system
i know i'm not really disagreeing with
you but i do disagree that there are
lots of good teachers
and in part there aren't lots of good
teachers because
the system doesn't provide enough
freedom if you're
a good teacher that means that you're
you have effectively been armed with
this mindset and then you are going to
absolutely bridle against the
requirements that are
put in your way and so the point is
by massively underpaying so that we
don't you know reward those who might
have a passion for it
and then hamstringing teachers basically
what we've done is we've
driven the talent out and that's not to
say that there are no good teachers left
there are but
um it is the exception not the rule
because it's people who have to have
all of these immunities and ability to
see past these stupid structures
in order to do anything that feels
reasonable
and i think frankly it's getting harder
and harder so yeah no it is it is
getting harder and harder i would say
you know it's it's not just the money
it's really it's easy to say and i
believe it to be true
and in fact i said the same thing as
well that we don't you know we don't pay
teachers
enough and that makes it harder to
attract the best and the brightest
that said back when back when we were at
evergreen and i was
um i was the faculty represented ran a
faculty representative for the council
of faculty representatives in washington
state for one year
which is to say evergreen and the other
oh boy uh
five four-year public schools in the
state of washington
um all met once a month on one of the
campuses and then during the ledge
session
we would go and um you know speak the
needs of higher ed to
the to the state um at least that was
the idea it didn't really
work out that way um but at one point
early on
we ended up with uh basically pay sheets
and there were
representatives from university of
washington and washington state
university the you know the two phd
granting institutions
in the state of washington that are
public uh as opposed to western central
eastern and
and evergreen um which are masters level
institutions i think still and
the pay for faculty at uw and
at uh washington state and indeed at the
other three
um was all sort of as you
expect for faculty and they
somehow were complaining you know there
was a legitimate complaint about
how low high school teachers pay was
because the idea was that if we get the
pipeline better we'd be getting better
college students in
and when i looked at these numbers of
what high school teachers were being
paid in most parts of the state
they were higher than what evergreen
faculty were being paid
so you know evergreen was famously
terrible at paying its faculty right and
this was actually
this was after our pay had climbed a
little bit but was still just quite low
and yet um what we used to say and i
think you innovated this was we got paid
in freedom
um so yeah we we made plenty to and yeah
it was cheap to live in olympia so
you know we made plenty to live to live
nicely but you couldn't really move
anywhere else
on that pay um on on either the coasts
and buy a house with the kind of money
that we were making for most of the time
that we were there
um
what we had making less than most high
school teachers in the state
that they didn't have almost any of was
the freedom to make the decision
decisions to think about what we wanted
to teach what we wanted to
take students where we wanted to all of
these things and
increasingly the public k-12 system has
gives basically
no freedom at all to its teachers so i
don't know i don't know how you could
even tell
if there are how many good teachers
there are left in the system at this
point
like i can i can say we can speak for
hours
about what we actually think about uh
the faculty at evergreen and you know
we've made
snide comments in the past and that's
not what we're going to do here now
because we really know because there was
so much freedom that people revealed
themselves
with what they did and mostly did not do
but how would you even tell with regard
to the teachers given how
constrained they are by all of the
by all of the especially testing
protocols that are being handed them
well i mean a there's a sort of stance
to reason
criteria if the job pays like crap and
you have a
passion for it but you're unable to
deploy that passion because of all of
the
rules you go do something else yeah i
also hope that just
sort of matches the you know experience
and you know we do
meet occasionally these subversive
teachers who are figuring out how to
teach
in spite of the rules right um in public
schools
yeah in the public schools but um it's
i think the answer is just evident so
one last thing i want to say is
the problem is as soon as you get away
from a pure liberal arts bent the idea
is oh you're teaching for employers
right you're teaching to what the
employers want there is another category
right we could arm you to be good at
stuff
to be good at thinking to be good at
problem solving which means hey
you might become an employer we're not
trying to please employers we're trying
to make employers so
well this is i mean this is what you and
i used to talk about and and teach about
actually and present
to evergreen people when they would
listen when we were still there was
we need you know we need a reframing of
the liberal arts um that does not
simply inherit inherit the readings and
the philosophies
of a hundred years ago yeah but actually
imagines what it would be like
to be an informed and self-sufficient
citizen of the 21st century
yeah and i would add self-motivated
do the worst possible job on this front
and it means that everybody is waiting
for somebody to tell them what to do
and it's a disaster predictably
absolutely we have to figure out how to
build self-motivated problem-solving
people which frankly will be happier
more effective uh more economically
productive people too
absolutely hey let's do that let's do
that let's do it
all right let's move on to questions
from the last hour i tried to get my
msnbc adult parents to watch
darkhorse it was too big a shock to the
system do you have any suggestions for
introducing folks to life
outside the cable news paradigm in a
non-threatening way
well have you tried restraints of some
kind
so that they don't really have a choice
i don't know that's a terrible answer um
it's a terrible answer yeah it's a
terrible answer no i don't
[Applause]
you know the people you're trying to
persuade and the problem is well but are
there are
can we think of any texts movies
you know if this is too much for them
yeah um
you know it it it might be that a clip
or two
uh from us but you know i think if this
is too much for them certainly you know
tim poole is
uh and uh you know sam harris might not
be
right like you know he's
well i mean i'm gonna i'm gonna go
hardline on this
i think the answer is you're talking
about
your people and figuring out how to get
your people to wake up to the fact that
certain
stuff that they have become convinced of
is
nonsense and that it is serving to keep
them
um imprisoned
in a
extractive paradigm that is parasitizing
them
i don't know how you do it i don't even
know if your people can be saved but
uh but if they can then the point is
there's a game which is how do you reach
somebody who's difficult to reach what's
the thing
that will cause them to think twice
about something they thought they had
they had nailed and uh
you know i'm always interested to hear
what works but yeah
in some sense it's very individual yeah
i mean it is i wish
i feel like i don't think you're trying
to evade the question but i think you
are
and um i'm trying not to evade the
question
and i can't think of what there might be
so i'm thinking
you know some some of the readings that
i have i have
read from here salchonitzen joseph
heller
pakistan um obviously orwell and
and i'll just huxley um are
so prescient and so relevant and yet i
don't know that they will seem so
to someone who is not yet um framing
what msnbc and cnn and wapo and new york
times
are are feeding us as as prescient as
as relevant right now so
um you know
boy i all right i take back my answer
okay you don't have to take it back
i'm looking for some additional text i
mean i get one
one thing is um not
all of them but megan dom has a new
podcast blocked and reported
and it's across it's across the board no
no that's uh no i'm sorry uh it's called
the unspeakable
the unspeakable podcast black and
reported is is katie and jesse
which i i wouldn't recommend in this
case i don't think that's that's the
right thing but megan dom's
podcast is is new and
not all of them would be relevant here
but she's got an interview for instance
with
um a uh a psychologist who specifically
works
on um on with with and on police
and she's got one um on
with a psychologist actually again um
who's thought a lot about
uh the the rising rates of trans in
teenagers
and oh boy and just a number of them and
she is so thoughtful and careful
and um and i i say this with you know
tremendous respect but like easy to
listen to she's she's
she's i i think she has a good chance of
maybe not be threat not being
threatening to people
who i i guess are threatened by us or
just they can't hear what we're doing
maybe
yeah i'm going to argue
john mcwhorter yeah um
jonathan height yeah but he doesn't i
mean he's not
what of jonathan heights well i don't
know i mean he's certainly
done plenty of stuff that you can find
on youtube
um let's see but i mean the coddling of
the american
mind titan looking on us book from two
years ago
um and the righteous mind i think
that would be you know anything again
that's that
that though the righteous mind is sort
of modern context-free just like
sulcinitzen
and uh you know and heller and and havel
so it's not about this particular moment
and i suspect that many people need
some particular like some of the context
of the particular moment to begin
to crack the facade that presumably
msnbc is
is providing yeah but if you let's say
um you read righteous mind and then you
look at
what height is doing in the context of
this
modern stuff right it's very hard to
dismiss him
right he's very very careful very well
grounded and i think quite hearable
and so you know it unfortunately may be
too much homework
yeah it's a lot of work but uh
but anyway i think i think it's at least
potentially a way in
what's next do you guys think that it is
possible that the pre-existing medical
conditions hit hardest by covid
are because the tissue that was used in
the gain of function research was tissue
from humans with these conditions
that's an interesting question i think
it is well within the realm of
possibility that we have to think
carefully about what the features are of
the disease
that would have come from uh these
serial passage experiments and what
tissues they may have been run in or
what creatures they may have been
running and it may have been both
so whether these pre-existing conditions
you know we've talked a little bit about
you know if you had
tumor tissue for example that tumors are
on are very poorly epigenetically
regulated
and that could be causing the very
eclectic nature of this
disease yeah you know that it invades
lots of different kinds of tissue
um so something like that is possible
whether the individual's had
the very particular pre-existing
conditions
i would say it is more likely that
you've got an unregulated tissue or a
poorly regulated tissue that therefore
simulates some of those conditions
rather than the patient that the tissue
came from had them
yeah i would um
i would tend to agree and i just don't
have a good enough sense of how the
inner
function research is run um to know
to have a lot of insight here but my
sentence like if this
if the lab original hypothesis is true
and it was gain of function research
that was happening in chinese labs
um then to my mind one of the one of the
places i go to when i see this question
as well one of the main pre-existing
medical conditions that seems to be
correlated with bad outcomes in covid is
obesity
and my sense is that there is far less
obesity
in the chinese population than for
instance in
western populations in the west
um and you know why yeah well i'm
struggling to think whether there's any
reason to think that they would have
used
tissue from chinese people well this is
so that's why it's like
well so i mean it's in chinese lab so
where are they getting oh they're just
this is just some
international source of tissue guess
would be that because
you know for valid reasons because you
want work to be comparable between
labs that probably there's some there's
some equivalent of the jack's lab for
human tissue right which
could be a vulnerability just as the
jack's lab is a vulnerability but i
don't know
yep could also be okay you know
you know yes it is possible either way
and i'm sure
people who are deeply ensconced in this
kind of work know the answer off the top
of their head but i
i don't
brett claims a great amount of liberal
pushback to
critical race theory he then names nine
liberal public intellectuals out of
three thousand
i can think of thirty total in the real
world and i am a socialist
um is this in-group bias clouding
i don't get i mean i know what the
question means right i don't get it it
feels to me like
you know another version of you know
mostly peaceful protest
right so if you have
nine i mean you know it's not like the
list stopped at nine nine
was the ones that i found that had a
direct connection to the wall street
journal
uh opinion page well i guess i
to steel man both this question and
actually that wall street journal
article by was jason reilly is that who
we decided wrote it
um uh
the public intellectuals i think are far
quieter
and therefore basically misrepresent
what the rest of the people on
you know among the liberals who aren't
given voice because they don't have
pieces
in you know on op-ed's pages of papers
are actually thinking so you know you
and me being certain
that there is a tremendous number of
people it is
that it is the silent majority of people
on the left who actually are looking at
scans at this
and you know maybe going along because
it doesn't feel that dangerous
or actually beginning to get really
antsy about it
that it's a really large number of
people is not the same thing as arguing
that it is a large number of
public voices on the left and i don't
it's not a large
number of public voices on the left and
it's certainly not a large enough number
of public voices on the left
who are criticizing this on the other
hand so what we did say
when we were talking about this last
hour was in part
when you do start talking about it um
you get told you're on the left and you
get to shut up and you lose your
platform and you know you know all of
these things
um that people say about cancel culture
and such are
are true uh and so you know that it
is exactly pushing people into silence
when they might not
otherwise be silent yeah um so
i want to be a little bit careful the
i don't think that it's a majority that
are just keeping their mouth shut
i think people start out knowing better
and then they take a step on the
slippery slope and then they convince
themselves of this woke nonsense
um out of self out of an instinct to
self present i don't know what those
numbers look like i hope it's still a
majority
but i want to be really sure that the
pushback here
is clean because there was something
very bizarre
about that opinion piece
okay okay it literally said you and i
found the same quote and we didn't talk
about it okay
yeah right where are the liberal voices
pushing back we find conservatives
pushing back
where are the liberals right this was
written by somebody
in the wall street journal where
somebody at the wall street journal
editorial page could have said well
there are some in fact here are several
articles that we've published
on our page exactly the same page that
you're publishing this so that was your
group
that was your list of nine was right off
the they weren't all
published there but they were all
published or mentioned or
clearly would be the page would be aware
of them um
so i would have expected you know if the
author had been
uh just somehow unaware then i would
have expected the page in the editorial
process to say actually it's not really
it's not that bleak right which would
have then resulted in a change in that
sentence which didn't happen
somehow but even weirder jason reilly
the author
follows all of us i believe it was every
single person i mentioned is in his
list of people that he follows on
twitter and not newly so it's not like
he just became aware of us right
this goes back what must be years
following us so
how can somebody who is aware of all of
us and
knows full well you know that we keep
saying
we're liberals this doesn't track for us
how
could such a person write that sentence
and then how could the page
sign off on it it's just well it might
you know maybe it's
maybe we are reading it wrong maybe the
intention
is to push people to speak up and say no
here we are
for god's sake this we we understand
that this is a problem
you know there there are a lot of ways
to get people to act
that are legitimate but not
straightforward yeah but this is
this is a newspaper and it's the wall
street journal and it's a wall street
the wall street journal which
was farsighted enough to actually
let us write for them and not to you
know sanitize what we wrote so it looked
like it came from conservatives so
anyway something odd happened i don't
think we're ever going to know what it
is
but something odd happened and it
shouldn't have happened because at the
very least if you're going to make the
claim
there aren't enough liberals standing up
against this which is a fine claim
and the answer is there are some but why
aren't there more
like these folks and then it raises a
question well what has your experience
been
experiences i keep getting portrayed as
a conservative right
yeah like so you know anyway something
else should have happened yep
next question i think the mostly
peaceful argument surrounding riots
riots has been debunked why does this
not work as an argument for the
anti-racists
replacing it with society being mostly
non-racist
yeah so first oh go ahead well no um
um in part because um
the mostly peaceful stuff was sort of it
be it started to be on the water like it
was all of these media platforms who
were making this claim
and you know it depends on what you mean
by mostly it depends what you mean by
peaceful and they all had these
different definitions all of which were
[ __ ] but they were all defending it
through these sort of
um you know anything ranging from
dimwitted to nefarious means i would say
and
compare that to anti-racism is a very
specific ideology
created by a very specific person
ibrahim x kendi
and it has a very precise definition
which is [ __ ]
but it's not this amorphous thing so you
know people who are saying well i'm not
anti-racist well then you're racist
candy says so and people don't respond
to that by saying you know candy says so
they may not even know that but the fact
is it does have this thing at base which
is
crazy it's crackpot it's nasty it's
divisive it's racist all of those things
but it is a it is a is a real thing at
base that
is yes the creation of the you know
fever dream of ibrahim x kendi but boy
he's winning with it
and it does mean that there's something
you can go back to and point to
yeah i mean i think in part there's
enough complexity
surrounding racism and enough
amorphousness
that it doesn't track as cleanly and
we're not going to know what role we
played in
breaking free of that
you know mostly peaceful nonsense but
before the mostly peaceful argument
broke into a thousand pieces uh we did a
little
riff where we were talking about my back
of the envelope
calculations in which the presidential
motorcade
in dallas in 1963 was you know above 99
peaceful and so anyway it was the
peaceful list
so the point is there is a way to say
there's a way to use this mostly
peaceful stuff to reveal
that it means nothing right what isn't
mostly peaceful yeah
well and i guess um also it also doesn't
if you yourself have not engaged in the
protest at all it's easy
and if you've only engaged in the actual
peaceful protest you know like during
daylight i don't really know what it
looks like in the other cities but you
know in in portland if it's during
it's during daytime they've been they've
been actually peaceful
um and they're real legitimate
protesters out there um
you can just say without any worry that
anyone is going to accuse you of having
been not peaceful accuse you of having
been violent like no that wasn't me i'm
not like i know that i participated in
a peaceful protest right whereas this at
the the
threat of being accused of being racist
has become
you know i'm not the first person to say
this but it's like being accused of
being a
child abuser like you know it's it's
this thing like no
no i'm not oh my god i'll do anything at
all to avoid being called that
and so it is much more easily weaponized
um in part because of the fear of being
called it and that works in part because
it is a personal accusation
rather than a society level accusation
yeah i think that's a good point
we know next question we know that two
parents are better than one parent
but does the sex of the parents matter
does having both a mother and father
matter
is there data on kids with same sex
versus hetero parents
is this an uncomfortable truth it's a
really good question it's a really good
set of questions
um i don't know if i'm sure there are
data
on kids with same sex versus uh
different sex parents and i don't know
what those data are
um but we have said
and we haven't we've been back written
into into the book that we're writing
um that if you don't have uh
both sexes of parents in your household
that you should um
work harder to make sure that your
children are exposed to
trusted adults of the sex that is not
represented in your household
it doesn't need to be a parent but it
needs to be someone who's close enough
that they can actually do some of the
jobs of parenting and modeled behavior
of just you know a representative of
that sex uh for your children so they
have
trustworthy models growing up yeah
i would say there's reason to wonder
about this um
that there are kinds of
wisdom and skill sets that have traveled
the female
line their a corresponding set or an
inverse set that have traveled the mail
line they need to get there somehow
right you want the full set of skills
there's a question about you know but
it's not just the skills either it's
just like
it's role modeling right and no matter
how
no matter how awesome a role model i am
for our two children
they're boys and i don't want them
looking up to me and saying
i want to be mom when i grow up right i
i want them to
you know to learn from me and to develop
things and habits that i have and to
also learn from me and
and not do things and develop habits
that i have
but in terms of how it is that they will
engage with the world as much as you and
i have shed
more of the gender stereotypes than
almost anyone else
i know you're their father and they're
boys and they're becoming men
comforting to hear it is my claim that
has been from the beginning i'm sticking
with it
all right putative father of those two
children um now you are their father
and and you are you are the model to
which they are they um they should
aspire more closely
even though um even though there's very
little about what we do
um that is at all um
sex uh typical no
sex mandated yeah yeah so that's true
and it's not just the you know you're
gonna grow up to be men
you need to have a model for that
there's also
you know a model of a relationship and
you know assuming you're straight
there's a model of you know
what is a woman what is it likely to be
like to
interact with one so there's a lot of
stuff that needs to be modeled that said
yeah um you know i think the
conversation would be
missing something if it didn't recognize
the possibility i mean within
you know gay culture there is a lot of
variation around these
gender norms right and so anyway
i think i think what i would say is my
personal suspicion is
that there is not that having two
parents who love you
and a world of examples from which to
draw
is probably way
better than um
a huge swath of of hetero families
right yeah you know or one parent who
loves you but is so
stretched so thin by virtue of the
economic realities of the situation so
you know i guess what i would say is
yeah there's probably some almost being
equal
all else being equal there is liable to
be something um
but you know but the ways we damage kids
are so many
that you know i don't see it as a big
factor relative to all you know to
allowing advertisers to access your
children and you know
reschedule how often they're hungry
right like that's a no
you could even argue that since you know
since gay couples
uh inherently have family by choice
they ne they never fell into being in a
relationship with their parents with
their child's
other parent and therefore ended up with
a family before they wanted to um that
they
their greater intentionality may result
in greater preparedness and skill
yeah i'm not i don't know that that's
true but i can see an argument in that
regard as well
yes if you're gay and in a committed
relationship it it's not likely you will
accidentally end up with children yeah i
think that's what i just said that is
yeah just
oh geez dude you didn't tell us we gotta
switch to the next one um
okay let's do one more question here and
then we'll go over into the questions
from
this next this hour um oh this is just a
comment
do point folks to the interview with
zubi the concepts discussed in an open
manner will help many in their
understanding of recent events in my
humble opinion
okay so i think that may i don't know if
that's responsive i don't these aren't
in order anymore so i don't know if
that's responsive to that earlier
question about what
the guy whose parents found darkhorse
too much um
but maybe i don't remember enough about
what was in the zoo interview
um to to know if that might work but
um maybe maybe parents who are msnbc
adult
is the phrase of the person asking the
question um
i don't know i could still hear the
zooby interview i don't know if this is
a reference
to the darkhorse zooby interview or the
one on
zooby's podcast your interview with
zooby or zooby's interview with you
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know okay
um okay we'll try this now okay
oh really really militant moderate
some love pimple pop videos some can't
stand them more adaptive to enjoy or
dislike might they balance out so we
pick just the right amount of zits
i didn't know these existed me either
nope
you really need a video you can't figure
this one out yeah i feel like i could
figure it out
yeah gross um i think i think he got a
um oh boy if you're watching a lot of
zip-popping videos yeah i think you need
to take a good look at yourself in the
mirror
and pop your zits that way
okay good wow thank you for discussing
solzhenitsyn and his live not by lies
essay
have either of you heard about or read
rodri rod dreher's book
named for the essay and released last
month thank you for everything
no i know i know of him um
i did not know that he had written a
book based named for that essay
uh look into it zach would you just
highlight that
so i can go back to it since it's uh
yeah
15. hail professors to promote more
respectful discussion within our society
should we bring back dueling
if there are consenting adults full of
hate should we allow them to engage
defend honor pros and cons please
totally that's it
i mean i don't know um officially
no unofficially sure consenting adults
full of hate
should we allow them to engage to defend
honor
[Music]
um
i really can't say yeah um probably not
i take your point
and i i find it funny yeah but uh
but yeah probably we should not revive
dueling um
on the other hand it's not like there
aren't some people i wouldn't mind
seeing
yeah dueled dually dueled
do you believe in hypnosis or are you
transphobic
um you think that's directed at me
no i think that's directed at both of us
i think it's it is i think it is both a
play on words transphobic
uh and it's a real question uh oh
transphobic sorry it's
blurry at that distance got it
uh yes so um
hypnotherapy is real and uh
it the the versions of it that are
in movies and such are caricatures of of
what it is
i don't think we have a full
understanding of
of what all it can do um but
but it is a real and
powerful tool uh among many in the human
arsenal that can be used
to help modify behavior and and change
motivational states
and alleviate pain as well um
yes uh that said i am completely immune
to it
apparently well based on that one
yeah one attempt but so i'll bet we
could try a hundred times
yeah probably yeah um i would also say
beware darren brown i know it's
very tempting but my sense is
the darren brown illusion works
but you are the mark you and the
audience
are the mark well he certainly does
hypnosis um
so anyway yes i'm not a believer in
in darren brown okay yeah you just you
changed the question
i did yeah but i mean it's bound to be
on people's minds because it's very
compelling yeah
actually it hadn't occurred to me that's
what the question was about and i barely
know who he is
whereas as you know um
you know i have an extremely good friend
um who
is both a clinical psychologist and a
hypnotherapist and uh
has has had remarkable success
uh working with people who's whose
problems were otherwise seemed
intractable
yeah no i do i do think it is a what it
is we don't know but
yeah that it is a route into some
intermediate state in which there's
plasticity and
i mean she's clearly very good at what
she does well i mean that that's exactly
it
in it but you know if she was extremely
good at what she
was and it was a farce she still
couldn't accomplish
what she does no no by by by saying
she's extremely good at it i'm
saying it's clearly a real space she
wouldn't be
wasting her time on if it wasn't right
um that said
i don't think you can reach everybody
that way because i yeah
no i don't think i don't think you can
either and i will um
i guess you know this this is pure
anecdote but
um after after the boat accident for
you know four and a half years ago in
galapagos um
she made me she made me a tape to listen
to and just said just
just lie on the floor and listen to this
it's like i don't know
10 12 minutes um every day really for
how long
until you don't anymore uh and
uh it you know it's it's not what people
have in mind
i didn't i wasn't being sent into trance
or anything but
um the the power to use
cadence and words and non-linguistic
sound that appears to be linguistic
uh to change perception and i think to
change uh healing rate and trajectory
is remarkable that was my sense
next up this is a donation to test the
hypothesis
by releasing helium from a tank from a
balloon store in the garage
not too much boom side note oh so that's
helium yeah not hydrogen i said helium
no but no boom i've got that yes
there wouldn't be a boom because it's
helium i didn't say that that's in the
question
sideways in the question side note lots
of math squaring here greater than 95
but cases are rising fast parenthesis
schools
uh so without knowing where you are or
what's going on
i don't know my suspicion is that
as people begin spending more time
inside with windows closed we're going
to get cases rising even if masks are
supposedly being worn because
masks are imperfect and even people who
are wearing masks sometimes
aren't um yes and in fact the
upgraded model that we have we talked
about a couple live streams ago
about aerosolized transmission the masks
don't work if you're in an environment
that saturates
with these aerosolized particles because
a lot of stuff is going around them and
basically you breathe it long enough
you'll get it so
yeah paying attention to airflow airflow
and saturated environments uh you know
masks are good for transient exposures
if you walk into a room that's full of
coveted you will reduce the likelihood
of contracting it yeah and big volume
spaces are better than small volume
spaces so here's a place where like
vaulted ceilings like you find in
grocery stores is actually going to make
those
spaces probably safer if the hvac is
um doing anything useful at all yep um
as to the first part with the
helium yeah this is
the test of the hypothesis i probably
should have mentioned it would be to get
some
balloon helium at a party store and
bag a camera and put some
helium in there and see if we reproduce
the same
regular drop in signal yeah um
i haven't done it for a couple reasons
one
is can't find a party store i probably
could find a party store i have one of
these phones
from the future that tells you where
stuff like that is amazing
i know um but the other thing is it
takes time for the helium to diffuse
out of the mems chip and so you lose
access to your device until the
device wakes back up a few days later
and i'm just sort of reluctant
to do it but yes i probably should do it
i probably should do it
we should do it yeah we should do this
test and not you know doing it um in the
garage
you know might if that works on a camera
it might make sense to do it in the
garage as a next step just to follow
through but i'm not even sure it's
necessary
i mean let's put it this way the
prediction is that we will see the same
pattern of failure of the cameras with
the regular
uh dropped signal and i would say if
that happens then the answer is
it's helium that did it where did it
come from did it come from the smoke or
did it come from the geology and the
house being buttoned up that's the the
next question yeah
where can evolutionary principles be
applied outside of biology and where are
they commonly applied when they
shouldn't be
well i would say you've got
a problem that comes from the fact that
we group the sciences together as if
they're the same thing
right so we group biology with chemistry
and physics
that isn't correct grouping in the sense
that they are amenable to scientific
investigation
but it is not a correct grouping in the
sense that biology has purpose
right uh ultimately maybe it doesn't but
a biological creature behaves as if it
has purpose to increase fitness right
and the point is those realms in which
there is identifiable purpose
and complexity are properly analogized
to biology
so that is to say psychology
engineering economics those are the
places where evolutionary dynamics are
mirrored
and anthropology um everything
anything made of anything made of living
critters exactly
all of you know anything that might be
studied in the humanities or social
sciences
right on the other hand something like a
hurricane
has complexity but no purpose right it's
an inappropriate application
there but there's also the question of
so evolutionary principles so
you know selection might be understood
as an evolutionary principle an
adaptation might be understood as an
evolutionary principle
and selection as you have very
frequently
laid out selection can exist with a
tidal action on a beach
arranging rocks in a particular order by
size
and there's no you know there's there's
nothing biotic there it's certainly not
biology but that is selection in action
there's no adaptation there yeah so
adaptation is the thing
that is going to exist only at the
bottom that's exactly
the right distinction and the fact that
we subsume
selection into biology space is wrong so
right exactly hence
where lee smolen is in terms of
using principles for the universe
basically these are principles that are
upstream of biology
okay so where they commonly applied when
they shouldn't be
i don't i don't think that category
exists but they are often
commonly applied badly or
non-evolutionary
thinking which is cloaked and i'm
evolutionary now
is applied in places where it shouldn't
be and hence we get things like social
darwinism
and eugenics and all sorts of other
really bad [ __ ] crazy thinking that
um rides around looking like evolution
but it's not yeah now where does it
absolutely neces
where is it absolutely necessary
medicine psychology
dentistry ophthalmology these are places
where it is largely absent and
the cost to us is absolutely immense
yep economics economics it's
it's already there because so evolution
and economics sort of co-invented game
theory yeah i mean axelrod and hamilton
is right there like at the sort of
origin
so in fact in that case i would say a
lot has to go the other way
right so diminishing returns is invented
inside of
uh in economics yeah and it's not an
economic principle
it's an evolutionary principle that
works in economics and so you have to
actually pull it out to the higher level
um
very important that you do yeah
hi please respond to social media forces
people
excuse me social media forces people who
never leave the house to encounter
reality in a way they never have and
that scares them
it also allows the same people to
exercise power in a way they never have
before
true on both fronts i would say um and i
think
i assume that the person writing the
question is using the phrase who never
leave the house
with some hyperbole you know everyone
almost everyone leaves the house a
little bit but
people really do have narrower and
narrower scopes
of experience especially this year you
know especially since march of this year
but increasingly people who got
the number of people i see evidence of
on social media
who's you know who are you know fighting
the good fight and being woke
and saying you know i'm a i'm a dad and
i'm a parent of two and you must be
racist
like i don't think you've ever been
anywhere have you like you
you actually are afraid of the rest of
the world and you lecturing me
about uh eurocentric vision of the world
i don't think you actually know what
that would even mean
like why don't you actually go somewhere
and talk to some people who don't look
like you
um maybe even a different language even
if you don't really speak that language
have a beer with them
sit down you'll be able to communicate a
lot even without much shared language
see what that's like and then get back
to me about how we're all racist
like seriously let's let's talk after
you've gone out and experienced
something
that's not like everything else you've
ever experienced i think most people
haven't done that increasingly more i
don't know most more and more people
increasingly
haven't managed to be able to do that
outside of their own sphere yeah
which is less and less incentivized to
the extent that you can source
little bits of uh excitement and what
feels like
exposure it feels like exposure but it's
not because it's totally
safe because nothing can reach out and
shock you or
hurt you or surprise you or make like
it's totally safe
and therefore it's totally sanitized so
um i think also though implicit in the
question
is and i must say i'm involved in a
private conversation an ongoing one
i'm not going to out anybody but there
is
a conjecture in this conversation about
people who are socially uncomfortable
and maybe not especially well skilled
playing a larger and larger role in our
online interactions with each other yes
and that basically that
sensitivity is manifesting in uh
dysfunctional ways that we're sort of
all becoming dysfunctional
in the context of these rules that can't
possibly be adhered to
and and things like this so i do think
there's interest to it yeah i think
absolutely that's true
yeah yeah it's not just that we're all
being made worse but that
um what's driving it is some some subset
of people who
started out more dysfunctional than most
of us yeah yeah
good afternoon to you both what do you
imagine is the evolutionary explanation
for fainting goats
i own four of them i can't quite figure
out how they survived without human
intervention
thoughts i never quite remember
what the story is on fainting goats i
this is one of these things that it just
like it enters my head briefly
and it there's something that seems so
amorphous or not quite real about it to
me that i don't remember
what the story is you got it no i'm in
more or less the same same boat i think
they are
i think they are domestic goats so
they've been they've been created by
humans
right which basically somebody's
selected for somehow well we selected
for something and fainting campaign
that's why i said somehow yeah
selected for something that was
associated with fainting or maybe some
some yahoo decide to actually select for
fainting who knows well it could be you
know you could imagine
that a goat you know obviously we don't
raise goats for
wool but let's just say that you had an
animal like that you could
select for sudden passivity right
so i don't know that well
i'm not saying i don't i mean fainting
is sudden passivity i just hadn't
framed it that way in my sudden
catastrophic passivity
right yes i've never actually suffered
sudden catastrophic passion certainly
i'd never know you to do so
yeah we'll get you the goat salts right
but
um yeah so anyway there could be
something you know
to select for that would directly reward
that there could be something
where you select something that carries
it along as a byproduct
um but unless it's wild goats then the
question doesn't really
exist on the other hand yeah right
possums play possibly i just yeah yep um
because it causes animals that are
reluctant to eat
uh already dead prey to mess with them
so and they do smell actually it's it's
interesting when you just said that it
occurred to me
um the possums who are the organisms
that play dead as a way of not getting
eaten
come pre-smelled so so it's it's a more
compelling
behavioral defense than it would be if
they smelled fresh
and also goats smell goats and
everything associated with goat's smell
what do they smell like uh there's like
there's a kind of a
goatee smell that is yeah on you can
detect in some
goat cheese goat milk so are you
proposing that
maybe they're they're playing dead i am
saying that is a hypothesis here that
makes
predictions i'm not saying i believe
that's the case but i believe
it's it's if it turns out that wild
goats
faint ever yeah then that would be the
next place i would yeah
sure i don't know what's going on behind
our curtain here but
someone is definitely not playing dead
yeah
yeah something like that yeah okay uh
let's get a couple more of these
in here uh this
is going to be a recommendation of
something to look at jerry pornell
phd's better political access um
oh is that an alternative to the
political compass i guess
um so i can't quite it's hard for me to
i can't
i can't i can't do it here because it's
in drive and it's not working
um we'll take a look okay
is the legalization of human vices like
gambling prostitution and drugs
of net benefit to society as a safe
outlet or of net detriment
well that's a small question isn't it um
i don't think i don't have the same
answer
to all of those yeah i agree it's
different depending upon which one
yeah so it's not just human vices but
gambling prostitution drugs
and you know then within drugs um even
even gambling has multiple
things like you know i feel i feel
differently
about um making it really easy for
people to waste their
their money on computerized slots
in gas stations uh than the prospect of
you know betting on the outcomes of
races for instance yep um it just
there's
there's much more at stake you just
again
you just have more skin in the game and
you there's more of a narrative
structure it's more of a community
possible well there might even be
something real
i mean yeah being able to interpret
which horse is likely to win under what
conditions
there might be some skill fields right
so it's at least in principle not
empty the way a a slot or even worse a
computerized slot yeah would be yeah um
again you know poker is real yeah court
cards is even more real
you know there's the underlying card
game and then there's also the human
dynamics meeting the people
you know who's bluffing so that could be
that could have
value in it the question poses it as an
outlet
i've wondered about this with respect to
prostitution
and on the one hand you would imagine
that prostitution probably reduces the
amount of
rape in the world because uh there's
likely
you know an outlet on the other hand
uh prostitutes are very vulnerable so it
channels
some of that violence onto a vulnerable
population
and that whole conversation is so
so damaged right now by the so-called
sex positivity movement right
which wants us to celebrate all outlets
of sexuality at all times and
simply say that sex workers are doing
you know
admirable and amazing work it's like no
you can you can simultaneously say
that some forms of prostitution probably
should be legal
for the safety of prostitutes frankly
and also simultaneously be trying to
absolutely minimize
um 100 percent minimize
sex work in in the world yep
but i would i would also add there is a
question
about what the effect um on
relationships is yeah in other words to
the extent
that um the normal situation basically
uh uses sex as an incentive to maintain
uh you know good relations with somebody
to the extent that people have an
economic outlet to free them
uh it may be very bad for relationships
and so absolutely
anyway certainly an interesting question
i think you would want
um you would want systematic study of
what the consequences
is you know in similar situations that
have different rules about these things
and then you know with regard to drugs
such as you know there's drugs isn't a
thing right we've already we've got some
legal drugs already
um and we've got a lot of drugs that are
not legal and
um this is a longer conversation
but you know at one level at first very
broad brush
pass the drugs that have been
synthesized and enhanced and
concentrated in lab
and then are taken in high concentration
form into the body
are um are likely to be the ones that
are most dangerous and should most 100
percent be kept away from
um you know almost anyone knowing that
they're out there in the world and
people are still going to find them
but um the question of say legalizing
hallucinogens
both strong and weak uh versus uh
cocaine um are really those
conversations should be happening in
different places well and
cocaine versus coca and
um heroin versus opium yep
right these are very different questions
so it's the concentration that makes
these things lethal
yeah um and that is not necessarily the
molecule itself
yeah what are you planning to do when
you go in the voting booth
hearing your interviewer describe a vote
for orange man as a stay of execution
felt apt your interviewer
trying to remember who this would be i
don't know was it zoobee no say
don't know okay anyway it doesn't matter
yeah um
i won't be voting for trump or biden
yeah i'm voting
i will vote i will vote i have always
i've voted in every single presidential
election i think i might have missed a
midterm
um or two but i voted every time
uh i have voted
i voted third party once before and i
didn't last time and i regret it
yeah i voted for two clintons i did not
vote for bill in 96
i voted green because i couldn't stand
him already
but i did vote for hillary last time and
i resent it i regret it
and uh i won't vote for either of the
parties this time
most important vote most important vote
i ever cast was for bernie sanders in
the general election of 2016
which at the time seemed uh pointless
pointless
and it turned out to be really important
so anyway
yeah i think the the necessity of
reading ourselves with the system that
keeps giving us
unacceptable choices is so great
that uh as much as i understand the
arguments against doing it
it's the only path yeah um the cat is
blocking my screen
oh is he all right there we go
do you concede to the possibility of you
being unable to honestly look into and
talk about conspiracy
theories either due to lifelong
mainstream media conditioning or out of
fear for your reputation
are there any conspiracies you believe
jfk 911
so the beginning do you concede to the
possibility of you being unable to
honestly look into and talk about look
into and talk about are different
right um i mean i think i think that's
that's the key well look into and talk
about are different and
um lifelong mainstream media
conditioning or out of fear for your
reputation are two different possible
reasons so
um we've talked about between ourselves
an awful lot of things much of which we
have not yet shared publicly some of
which we may never
why why don't we why don't we talk about
everything that we why don't we talk
publicly about everything that we talk
about privately
i think the question um
reveals the problem right as soon as you
say conspiracy theory
my sense is you're [ __ ] up right
not conspiracy theory conspiracy theory
if we use the term
theory consistently means a
hypothesis of conspiracy that has
withstood
test right it is a proven conspiracy
so conspiracy hypothesis
i believe we are in a better position to
talk about that than most people because
there is
discipline to be had surrounding the uh
the underlying logic the philosophy of
science that goes into knowing what did
and did not take place
involves advancing hypotheses
predictions that would tell you if they
were true and then testing them so
um anyway i feel at liberty to talk in
the context
of conspiracy hypotheses i feel
jeopardized by the fact that if we talk
about a conspiracy hypothesis
there is this eagerness to immediately
say ah you're advancing conspiracy
theories it's like no
i said hypothesis for a reason right so
if the world would be better at
recognizing the distinction between
somebody who is talking
in the context of hypothesis where we
know what it is that will
validate or discount uh any particular
instance then fine then we can have
great conversations
if we're going to talk as if people who
entertain conspiracy hypotheses
are conspiracy theorists well then now
you've got a trap
it's a kafka trap and i don't want to
play that game so
anyway let's do it properly okay let's
do it properly let's just get a little
bit
drill down a little bit more on the idea
that
um has lifelong mainstream media
conditioning
made it impossible for us to even
consider
some some possible uh
avenues here i don't i don't actually
think so because
well i because i know the extent of the
things that we have
looked into and considered and talked
about right and you should be too
and yet and many of which still wonder
you know there's just the jury is out on
a lot of these ideas
and it's not it's not worth talking
about some of them publicly
yet maybe ever but um
there's a lot of bat [ __ ] sounding ideas
that may not actually be untrue well but
you know
glorious thing about using hypothesis
for its intended use is the fact that
one advances a
hypothesis that involves a conspiracy
doesn't mean that you necessarily think
it even happened
right it just means you're saying here's
something that might explain
x y or z and here's how you would know
seconding in motion to have dr steven
porges
poor guess i'm not sure uh on to discuss
polyvagal theory
it's pertinent to our times and based on
evolutionary biology lots of love
uh i've heard of polyvagal theory i
can't i can't place it
at the moment yes i think i may have
promised to look it up and then didn't
okay so
exactly looking it up would you
highlight what i've got highlighted
there if you know if that makes sense
um i don't know how to answer this next
one what is your longest standing
disagreement
our longest standing disagreement yeah
these are longest-standing i don't know
um
[Music]
i mean at one level this is the kind of
question like what's your favorite
movie that in the like
what's your favorite movie wouldn't be a
good question but like you know what are
your top
10 pieces of media that you've enjoyed
like
being asked that question i i have a
memory break
um so it's possible i'll come up with
something here but i
i'm not sure you know i'm not sure
exactly it's framed this way
i'm not even sure maybe that you know 20
minutes after we're done here it's going
to dawn on one of us
but i think in some sense the nature of
the relationship
is such that you know a disagreement is
either
trivial and therefore not likely to be
long-standing in the sense that
it's not going to be a topic that keeps
recruiting we might not resolve it but
we move on
right yeah or it's something that's
going to take
work to figure out what we actually do
believe and you know
there have been plenty of places where i
have thought something you have
thought something inconsistent with it
and i know in retrospect you were right
there are others where i was right and i
think the point is
maybe it's even
evidence of something being off if you
do have lots of long-standing
disagreements that you do you know is it
a kind of baggage that accumulates in a
relationship and so in fact in effect
what you want to do is put in the work
to actually figure out who's right or if
it's not either one of you then
what is it that you haven't figured out
about you know what explains
some discontinuity well there can be i
mean i guess there are a number of
ways that one can understand the word
disagreement right so
no two humans are totally compatible
with one another we will
i found it okay hold on though yeah we
will uh you know
two two humans living closely for
decades will drive each other crazy in
some ways
no matter what and um those things that
will be persistent could be understood
to be
a disagreement but more to the point i
think it would be a
sort of every now and again like okay
i'm going to check in like this thing
that we already know we aren't totally
sympatico on is driving me crazy at the
moment
and that's where i am and that's like
you need to know that that's in my head
at the moment so
that's not i don't i'm not thinking of
any particular examples but we could
we could come up with those you know
there aren't any that are you know
years old i don't think or you know
certainly not decades old
but there's certainly like repeated
types of things just because we are the
at some level the same people that we
have been forever so what did you come
up with
dark chocolate
i don't even know which way you think
this goes um
that that i like dark chocolate and you
don't yeah
okay i think that that
and you know i have been saying for some
time that
dark chocolate is objectively inferior
and that there is a way in which it is
fetishized well i
i feel like i grant that
but but you do have
dark chocolate rather than preferring
milk chocolate so i i batch
at the moment instead of sober october
we're doing sugar-free october so
there's i'm buying chocolate for the
boys to have and one of our children
doesn't
uh like dairy and so he doesn't like
milk chocolate and so i get dark
chocolate for him
um
often there are things
on offer in the dark chocolate area that
i find more interesting than what's
available in the milk chocolate and i
think in general the quality is higher
because
maybe in part because it has been
fetishized because like if you if you
can afford the slightly higher price
point
um and you know if they're going to put
dried cherries and
and almonds into the dark chocolate it's
going to be
delicious and the the comparable milk
chocolate might be a lower quality
chocolate and so
it's really hard to control for the
cacao content and the quality
simultaneously yeah i agree and there
are some places where
dark chocolate by virtue of its having
been mixed with something else is maybe
the right thing
yeah but on its own seems to me
no contest ever and you you found an
essay this year
and you argued this very forcefully
which i thought was
was beautiful but yeah um anyway from
what it was something about oh maybe it
was
it would have been about halloween candy
actually maybe i can find it again now
that halloween is coming up yep
okay um yeah interesting question
okay let's do let's do three more
the american solidarity party pro-labor
healthcare environment
family low low ginny
what's ginny um it is a
measure of economic disparity
gini is it an acronym coefficient yep
okay oh the geneva yes okay
uh anti-capital anti-capital punishment
not pun okay i'm gonna start over this
um american solidarity party pro-labor
pro-health care pro-environment
pro-family
low gini coefficient anti-capital
punishment
anti-abortion i think
anti-interventionist war social
democracy within catholic social
teachings
origin point of political matrix useful
beyond the present
i'm not sure what that last sentence
means i don't know
i don't know either um
most of that looks looks good to me
there's one thing on your list that i
have a problem with which is um
no access to abortion no i yeah i don't
want to say anti-abortion just like i
don't want to say you know
that would be the pro-life position um
but i'm i'm
pro-choice at least for um early term
and
and uh evidence throughout the world
suggests that uh
women who have access to abortion end up
in society
in societies where women have access to
early term abortion those societies
uh have even just economic measures like
higher gdp and higher levels of
education of both men and women
lower birth rates obviously maybe
and just higher levels of productivity
without necessarily just producing more
kids
so there are a lot of reasons that i am
i am
pro-choice but otherwise everything on
that list seems
interesting and relevant i'm not sure
what the final question
means origin point of political matrix
useful beyond the present
you know what that means i don't yeah
and you know anything about the american
solidarity party
no i can't say that that rings a bell
not for me either i haven't heard of it
next question might humans have a
predisposition to mate with those of
different ethnicities
it seems mixed-race offspring are better
looking and more intelligent than
average as compared to the polar
opposite
in breeding
let's put it this way this is a topic
that gets ugly pretty
quick but from the point of view
of males looking
to reproduce without commitment then yes
you would expect this
for reasons of genetic intragression
so there will be many circumstances in
history that reflect this predisposition
it doesn't mean
that necessarily the same predisposition
will exist
in the context of high investment
relationships you would predict a much
more
complicated pattern for both males and
females it would depend a lot on
various costs and benefits which you
could do the analysis but anyway
topic for another time um it's a good
one but it's not going to be a simple
answer
yeah so i'm going to um drop down i just
scrolled through there's actually a lot
more questions that we're not going to
get to we'll get to some of them next
time
uh this one which is similarly fraught
but
related have you read a natural theory
of rape by randy thornhill and craig t
palmer
and do you believe there is some
credibility that the act of rape was not
about power but a biological trait for
primitive non-alpha males to continue
their genes
so the the
modern feminist trope that we are
expected to accept
that rape is just about power is clearly
wrong
obviously where did that even come from
where could that pot like what what what
would that even mean
um was it
a strategy that worked for some yes is
it a reprehensible and disgusting
strategy that should be
criminalized every place all the time
yes
uh yeah um back in the day and i at
least skimmed it um you know that that
was
sort of that that book 90s i think so we
knew randy thornhill
at the time um i will say
when that book came came out every
evolutionary biologist
working at the time had the same sense
that like
well this isn't exactly news yeah
obviously it's an evolutionary strategy
um but that this is making a big splash
based on taking something that we all
understood to be the case
and revealing it as if it was
provocative
now is it a low-ranking
strategy that can be it's not the only
context um so anyway what i would say is
war is another context well that's the
thing is this is in large measure how
war was paid for until uh a certain
point in history
so anyway there's lots of stuff and you
will find it uh
more or less described you know in the
bible there are
rules moses uh laws of war
describe things that you would have to
take to be
rape um and setting out rules for them
so anyway
yes there's a lot here it's a very
ancient strategy it's definitely
evolutionary
but rape is an evolutionary strategy
laws against rape are an evolutionary
strategy right this is more complex than
we give it credit for so
the problem with that book was the
implication of saying
rape is an evolutionary strategy
suggests that it
people jump to naturalistic fallacy
right like oh well then it's inevitable
then
what can you do about it like you can do
a lot about it and you and we need to do
a lot about it and we need to stop it
right the fact is you've got two
evolutionary strategies that doesn't say
either one of them is any good but our
values tell us
one of them is abhorrent and that you
know
making it so costly that people don't
engage in it is
obviously the right thing to do yep so
there's just a couple things about
helium here that maybe i'll
stop stop with and the next time we'll
come back around and get a few of the
other ones we didn't get to
uh too much helium might disable the
mems chip outright rather than altering
the frequency
um i believe that might be possible
these mems
they're very mysterious little objects
now my sense is that normal levels of
helium that might be encountered
uh diffuse in cause the object very
frequently
to be unusable for a period of time as
if it is dead and then
it slowly diffuses out and they revive
but could you damage the thing
permanently
i believe that is possible at least in
some cases
okay and please do the helium test on
camera
on camera recorded not necessarily live
stream but would be interested to watch
uh it wouldn't be fast enough would it i
don't know it might be
okay but it but what you don't want to
do is have a process that's slow
and therefore seems to falsify the
hypothesis that then later on turns out
to be right so
yeah it might be that you want to record
the entire test and then if it takes 10
hours
to trigger it the point is all right
here's the place in the test where we
first see the flaw
well that's why they said not live
stream just oh
right yes you got it right
and i'll just finish with this
appreciation comment thanks so so much
for this podcast
i've been starved for true intellectual
discussion during this lockdown it is
just wonderful to hear you both
regularly
thank you alex yeah thank you that's
great yeah
thank you very much and um and yeah
we're
we are so grateful for the audience and
for the support
and uh for you know for comments like
that
and the pushback that we get and the
support
so uh if if you do want to be involved
in conversations like this with other
people who
are interested in such conversations
join one of our patreons and join the
discord
come on to mind to get access to that
private q a
once a month the last sunday of every
month at 11 a.m pacific and then we
leave it up so you can
watch uh anytime although that's small
enough that we're able to actually
engage with the chat a little bit we
have so far been
um joined brett's patreon at a higher
level
um to join in on those conversations
that he has monthly conversations on
evolution and on
civilization very good conversations yep
and uh what else
i don't know maybe that's it like
subscribe
send a clip to somebody that uh you want
to
bring into the conversation that's right
all right we will see you next time
thanks so much
[Music]
you